los electorales vacíos una escena común
en muchas partes de irak este domingo ya
que los votantes se quedaron en casa el
gobierno acordó celebrar estas
elecciones parlamentarias de forma
anticipada en respuesta a las protestas
masivas de 2019 pero muchos de los
jóvenes incluidos los que están detrás
de las manifestaciones boicotearon la
votación brian mccann no hay ningún
candidato que merezca ser elegido
especialmente los antiguos
ya fueron nominados antes llevan 20 años
sin competidores
no nos hemos beneficiado de nada
horas antes de que terminara la votación
la participación nacional se estimaba en
torno al 30 por ciento
muchos de los 25 millones de votantes
elegibles boicotearon las elecciones
diciendo que habían perdido la fia en el
sistema democrático pero en algunas
partes como la capital bagdad aún había
esperanza de que la razón por la que voy
a votar es para sustituir a la clase
dirigente por sangre nueva que pueda
entender el sufrimiento del pueblo
iraquí juana de lara tnt
he votado porque es un deber nacional
tengo 70 años y uso un bastón pero mi
amor por mi país me trajo aquí mi ropa
los resultados preliminares se esperan
para dentro de 24 horas pero es probable
que las negociaciones posteriores se
prolonguen durante semanas el ganador de
la votación podrá erigir al próximo
primer ministro del país con el futuro
del actual humanista falcón un pendiendo
de un hilo pero muchos analistas creen
que cualquier cambio será limitado ya
que los principales bloques musulmanes
chiitas serán los que obtengan más
escaños